For the first time in four years,...
…the U.S. and South Korea will revive their live action military drills.
This is heightening their preparedness as the North Korean nuclear threat worsens...
...and China steps up its presence around Taiwan.
But there's concern that North Korea could use the drills as a pretext to retaliate.
Let's just take you now to Jean Mackenzie, our correspondent in South Korea...
…who was given rare access to the joint operations center...
…from where the war games are run.
Deep underground, an American and a South Korean colonel watch North Korea.
I'm learning, but it's difficult to get it right.
In this classified bunker outside Seoul,...
…the two militaries work together to defend against a North Korean attack.
This is the only place in Korea...
…where U.S. forces and South Korean forces sit side by side.
And using all this information,...
…they can detect almost immediately if North Korea launches a weapon.
Between his great English and my terrible Korean,...
...we can usually muddle through a lot of different things...
…and get to a decision quickly.